welcome back to on S I'm joined Now by
Israel's former prime minister ahu
Barack uh Mr Barack thank you very much
indeed for joining me I I greatly
appreciate it I want to start by playing
you an extract from an interview I did
with uh prime minister Netanyahu back in
March in the middle of all the big
social unrest in Israel over his
attempts to usurp the power of the
Supreme Court listen to this we don't
believe in Collective punishment I go
after the terrorists I go after those
who support the terrorists but I don't
believe in Collective punishment it
seems to me part of netanyahu's problem
has been that for political expediency
he's had to pack his cabinet full of
very hard-right people whose incend
rhetoric has done nothing but
fuel uh a lot of
Fury amongst the Palestinian people what
would you agree with
that you know the nomination of these
two racist
Messianic we call it in yish Michigan is
a grave mistake of netan
the areia within the Israel Society but
it has nothing to do with the crisis we
are now facing the uh Barbarian Massacre
that happened in October 7th started to
be prepared before nety government more
than a year ago before nanu government
was ever established and it has nothing
to do whatsoever they are there are a
huge damage to Israel in one more than
one way but they are not the direct
cause of these event and these attacks
when you heard about the scale of what
happened on October the 7th how did that
affect you personally you've been a
prime minister of Israel you've been a
general in the Defense Force what was
the personal impact on
you look I witness our people it was the
the most severe um blow that Israeli
suffered in the since it's establishment
we had never such an event well within
24 hours it's much more than 1400
probably we end up with
1,00 and um several hundreds
were c as hostages and they were
slaughtered slaughtered literally it's
not just a terror it's a crime against
humanity no one can remember such
pictures since probably Eastern Europe
during uh during World War II under the
Nazi Rule and that of course it shock
the public but we are defiant species we
know how to unite when we Face an
external threat we are united we
mobilize over
300,000 reservists to make sure there is
enough Force to avoid any kind of a
further surprise and to be able to have
a major offensive in the G strip we got
support from the whole world the prime
minister sunak is now in Israel but
Biden was there yesterday aircraft
carrier is closing even some British
vessels and uh We've enjoy a lot of
support and the third element which is
very important the you know in a way
it's not just a failure of the
intelligent a failure of the operational
side and in spite of heroic heroic a
response of the soldiers on the ground
it's still a major failure of our
defense system but it's also a major
failure of the of the political level
and basically they they lost the trust
of the people and the both the
government and in a way the military and
a important step was the Crea some four
days ago of a war cabinet make made of
netan and other four people two of them
were added from the opposition leaders
um gun and Isen they both are a career
generals before they turned into
politician both were commanders of the
Armed Forces of Israel and both are very
responsible cool headed balanced people
so in a way they're joining the war
cabinet make more citizen including
myself more quiet about the decisions
that might come out uh and translated by
the unfor into action I if this attack
had happened on your watch as prime
minister would you have
resigned I you know it depends to what
extent I would feel the situation I
don't want to answer it right now
because there is a the question of
course on the air in in regard to
Netanyahu I think that now we have to
focus first and foremost on response we
have to do something no modern State can
afford having it you mentioned earlier
911 if you think in the terms of the
population like Americans having 911
with 50,000 people killed not
3500s so it's a major blow we have now
to focus we have to eradicate any
military capability of
theas demanding enough job Mr let me
just jump in there because the
convention Outlaws Collective punishment
uh prime minister Netanyahu when I
interviewed him back in March said he
did not he did not believe in Collective
punishment and he wouldn't exercise
Collective punishment in the way he
dealt with Palestinians but many would
argue including my previous guest Hassan
pah that the fact that three and a half
thousand Palestinians have already been
killed in the last 10 days since October
the 7th does constitute a form of
collective punishment how do you go
after Hamas given that they are living
amongst the civilian population in Gaza
without exercising a collective
punishment are we not seeing that
now Israel is committed to the
international law no Israel Commander
ever get an order to a pilot to launch a
bomb on a hospital that's a crazy idea
and we can later on talk about it so we
are basically committed to it is a major
constraint on our operation uh we the
right way is to warn everyone we cannot
afford not acting against the Kamas so
we announce on the first day every one
of you gazans who know that the place
where he lives or the place where he
works there is now or there was in the
past let's say two years any Kamas
activity a launching pad for a rocket a
lab a munition or or weapons kind of a
Depot a kind of operational office or
what or trading site whatever you should
leave the place because we are going to
hit it and we said it once and again
every day some 4 days ago we announced
all gazans are asked to move to the
southern part of the Gaza strep in order
to allow us to hit the rest a half a
million moved another half million did
not move theas deliberately use them as
a a human shield deliberately try toour
them from living let me ask you this
what is a proportionate response 3 and a
half thousand Palestinians have already
died if there is a ground Invasion with
support from the air perhaps the sea as
well by Israel that number is going to
massively increase you're going to see
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians killed here at what point
does it become dis proportionate or
indeed as critics are already saying a
war
crime I strongly believe that if a
people will be focused enough to
understand that we are going to come we
are going to come with ground forces as
well because you cannot eliminate these
Barbarian dashik or alqaeda like groups
that are slaughtering civilians in our
border I'm confident that if the UK the
Great Britain would have a 10,000
British ER citizens a slaughtered H
literally by a
dashik group O over your border that
jumped in you would take whatever steps
I don't want to go into history and
remind you of Dresden and other
operation I want to remind you that the
the UK as well as the United States sent
its forces over half of the globe in
order to destroy Dash these are H
enemies of mankind and we have to get
rid of them now what happens okay listen
I agree with you but but what happens Mr
Barrett what happens no you
cannot look P you cannot ask me why the
citizens of Gaza are not leaving the
places where we announce them days ahead
of time we are going to go there it will
be tough we will use
fire because we had to get rid of the
phys Mr bar let me let me put it to you
it may be because this is their home
these are their houses this is where all
their possessions are it may be that
they think to themselves why should I
leave my home I'm not responsible for
what Hamas did why am I going to face
being kill because of
it if you or or me would have faced the
choice whether to be killed as a result
of staying there or leaving it and stay
alive I would at least I know that I
would have lived and they have the right
to live they have the go Mr let me ask
you where are where are all these
Palestinian people going to end up where
will they live they not not don't ask me
how it will end up once they leave they
move to the southern part of the Gaza
Street there is place for them we are
not going to operate for 10 years it
might take several weeks or probably two
months if there are more people inside
it uh we will fight Hamas we will
eradicate their infrastructure and their
capability of repeat this crime Israel
cannot afford having Hamas attacking us
in this way again and I am confident
than any elected government of any
country on Earth else would have done
the same and it's not inevitable that
they will killed on mass they can leave
they can leave now when we are speaking
they can leave tomorrow they can leave
next day it it's not coming within few
hours but you cannot blame us for the
fact that Kamas coer people to stay as
their human shield you will end up with
impunity to a kind of
dashik terrorist because they always can
can en handun hand some people including
the hostages I might say as a kind of
human shield for them and that will
paralyze Humanity from being able to a
struggle which is its more its worst
enemies and we are not going to stop to
stop it I'm confident that we we are
doing our best bet every Target is is
checked more than once by different
teams to make sure that it's
legitimate Mr leave it there ex all I
would say is is the world is watching
and Israel has got to I believe in
Israel's right to defense but there's
going to be a Tipping Point if Israel is
not careful if too many Palestinian
civilians are slaughtered in Revenge for
what happened October the 7th the world
the world mood will change and that will
be a dangerous moment for Israel and for
the world but listen we'll have to see
what happens and I realize you're I want
to
to I I have one one remark to me we
heard the same from the Americans even
without this advice which I fully
respect we are doing it any we fully
understand we have several constraints
on the operation one is the hostages the
second is the risk that it will spread
to the nor and become a regional War the
third one is a question to whom we will
pass the torch once we clean the the
area from Kamas we we are not going to
stay there for we need some player to
take it let's think
of
Arab multinational force that take
responsibility for three three or six
months and bring the original recognized
owner of the place which is the
Palestinian Authority or any other
variation on this and the last a sincere
constraint is the international law we
fully understand that this Universal
support of Israel will erode as the
number of collateral damage which happen
to be a it's a kind of
vague definition it's basically people
who are innocent and are killed we don't
like to kill people who are Innocent but
we
understand I have to I have to leave it
there I understand that but this
Collective punishment issue if it looks
more and more like that is what is
happening that will be a breach of the
Geneva Convention so we're going to have
to wait and see uh how this all plays
out PR I have to leave it there I'm
sorry I
do we won't understand we won't break
the Geneva Convention I would I would
hope that would not be the case uh
Edward barck I really appreciate you
joining me thank you very
much thank
you